you and I talked about Robert Downey jr.
and chaplain you want to talk about that
screen test a little bit all boy would
attest uh I don't know that everybody
knew that he was a student of chaplain
but we did and there was a test that we
did with him and a number of guys tested
but when he did the test he did a
backwards flip when he left the stage
and the money people the producers and
the director just went oh he was perfect
and we knew he was and we had followed
his career we had helped him we'd put
him in a number of pictures and and we
just knew the picture he had done just
before chaplain I believe one her
brothers had to pay eight hundred
thousand dollars for the insurance to
make sure he was going to be a good boy
he's a very good boy and today a great
star yeah he is I mean that's just
something that over the time that we
spend with these actors over the years
that you really knew that information
and gave him this opportunity because he
had starred in some films and was a an
supporting actor in a lot of films and
hadn't ever done a period film he'd
never really carried the lead I mean
this was a big risk it was a big budget
at the time I was 30 million dollars
that was huge yeah it was it was a big
budget in and of course the studio had
to take a chance on somebody because
there wasn't a name who could play
chaplain and so when they saw that test
it was the clincher it did it when one
has a very wonderful director I've been
blessed that Jane and I were blessed we
got to work with so many phenomenal
directors and not the least of which is
our friend who is here I think he's
still here Norman Jewison
and Jacqueline just turned out to be an
amazing film yeah well done and the
other thing we were going to talk about
is the the art of the ensemble cast
because we're looking for that seamless
combination of actors that will work
together as a unit and while each being
completely distinct in their own way and
I think one of the finest examples of
that is one flew over the cuckoo's nest
munich cast a spectacular well when
you're in the casting office and you you
get you you really find actors you can't
do anything with they come in you meet
them they talk to you and they go away
and you maybe don't see him again but
something about them you remember and
the characters that we were able to put
into that film we remembered and that's
the joy of being a casting director is
to meet all of these different people
and they bring such wonderful wonderful
abilities to the screen you don't really
know what those abilities are but you
feel something when they come in the
room and that's the thing people have
asked me well what makes a casting
director I don't know haste sure we all
talk about taste but what makes a
casting director is learning that little
tiny that's something that the actor who
has just come into your room has you
can't bottle it you can't sell it you
can't even describe it but you know know
it yeah and we were fortunate we were at
a time today David Rubin and I were
speaking a couple of weeks ago and we
were saying today a good casting
director
Rosalie is supposed to know hundred
thousand actors well that's nuts but
when uh when Jane and I were working
together we probably knew 3,500 or 4,000
actors and the good news is they weren't
all stars they were in all leading
players they were the secondary people
who made the pictures work because it's
the secondary people I think that it was
said earlier that the stars really get
cast by the studio by the director by
the producer because the studio needs to
put a name in their product so they
could get the money back so sometimes
it's not the star who makes the movie
it's the fulfilled cast it's all those
secondary players and they have to work
yeah and then there was Louise Fletcher
ah and that was she was probably a
second lead in the film and she came out
of nowhere I mean she had done some
small parts and work back but that woman
still gives me the chills I mean that's
a performance unlike I mean it's when
she walked through the door you must
have been thank God oh we were as normal
and and I don't know that everybody in
the audience will know this but when we
sent out to cast the second role in a
motion picture the studio is saying okay
well let's go for x y and z and x y and
z are all the big-name women of the age
and who have the ability to play the
role well they're not always available
or they don't want to do the picture and
then you get gold you get diamonds you
get something magical and it's something
that no one expected no now expected and
our our ex partner fred ruse had had
talked about Louise to me and he was
right
and she was right and she read and she
just knocked our head oh she was
phenomenal and she was in the picture